[Musique]
et
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
c'est parti pour 30 minutes d'actualité
européenne dans cette émission direction
le portugal tout à l'heure en deuxième
partie là-bas depuis maintenant deux ans
la pma la procréation médicalement
assistée est permise à toutes les femmes
cette loi n'a pas suscité beaucoup de
controverse alors qu emmanuel macron
souhaite l'ouvrir à toutes les femmes en
france
nous avons suivi martial jeune femme
d'une trentaine d'années qui tentent de
concevoir un bébé toute seule
débat tout à l'heure mais d'abord
l'actualité l'allemagne dans une impasse
politique les négociations pour tenter
de former une coalition jamaïque ont
échoué et plonge le pays dans
l'incertitude nouvelle tentative de
formation d'un gouvernement minoritaire
ou de nouvelles élections l'union
européenne est suspendu à ce feuilleton
berline noire on écoute le président de
la république fédérale et la chancelière
victoire avait pas eu d organiser de
nouvelles élections c'est une option
mais pour un pays stable pour un pays
qui a tant de défis à relever
il faut considérer avec prudence
l'option d'un gouvernement minoritaire
je ne peux rien dire aujourd'hui mais je
suis très sceptique sur le fait qu'un
gouvernement minoritaire soit la
meilleure solution
dastan brent et à bassorah diktat de
tous les partis qu'ils soient
disponibles pour le dialogue afin de
rendre possible dans un délai
raisonnable la formation d'un
gouvernement
celui qui se présente à des élections et
aspirent à des responsabilités
politiques ne peut se cacher quand il à
ses responsabilités et j'ai le plaisir
de recevoir pour en débattre marie arena
bonjour à vous êtes député belge membre
du groupe socialiste
en face de vos philippe juzan vous vous
êtes français vous êtes membre du groupe
ppe donc les républicains enfin et les
vestes courtes hassoun vous êtes
espagnol et vous êtes député vert qu'est
ce que vous avez pensé de cette impasse
politique en allemagne peut-être maria
arena est ce qu'il faut craindre au
niveau européen que cela bloque un petit
peu
toutes potentiellement toutes les
réformes qui étaient portées depuis
quelques mois je pense qu'il ya deux
choses la première c'est vrai que
l'allemagne était un acteur important au
niveau européen et donc bien entendu
toutes situations difficiles de crise en
allemagne est une situation qui impacte
sur le projet européen mais de là à dire
que le projet européen est à l'arrêt
parce qu'il ya une situation interne en
allemagne qui doit être gérée par
l'allemagne
je trouve que ça ça montre à quel point
certains pensent l'europe non pas comme
étant une entité européenne
mais quand est tendue mais plutôt comme
étant une entité intergouvernementale
dans lesquelles l'allemagne joue un rôle
je dirais presque exclusif au niveau
européen je m'oppose à cette vision de
l'europe
philippe je suis vin vous êtes d'accord
on est vraiment dans une vision
intergouvernementale ou bon soyons
pragmatique sans les allemands c'est
quand même compliqué d'avancer
évidemment enfin il faut pas se raconter
des histoires c'est vrai qu'il ya un
parlement c'est vrai qu'il ya une
commission européenne
tout ce matin peut continuer à
fonctionner sans canne états membres
soient présents à la table des
négociations mais on sait qu'en fait ce
n'est pas possible
l'absence des allemands bloque tout
processus important profond sérieux on
va continuer à légiférer sur des sujets
importants et qui ont déjà été réglés en
amour non l'absence de l'allemagne à la
table
locke toute évolution sérieuse l'europe
elle est hôtesse me diriez vous que
c'est pas un risque pour un gala merkel
de passer par un gouvernement
minoritaire
est-ce que des nouvelles élections
serait pas plutôt une meilleure solution
il ya plein de gouvernements
minoritaires en europe qui marche
moi ce que je pense qu'il faut
s'habituer quand même les grands partis
doivent s'habituer à que les paysages
politiques commencent à changer partout
il faudra faire des accords avec
plusieurs parties dans les prochaines
années passent sur des thématiques sur
des thématiques très concret donc c'est
pour ça moi moi par exemple dans la
négociation gg j'ai mal vécu le manque
de sensibilité envers les questions que
mes copains des écologistes ont mis sur
la table il n'y avait pas vraiment de
volonté d'élargir un petit peu le
programme vis-à-vis d'autres partis
politiques qui sont présentes dans la
table et par rapport à l'europe moi je
pense qu'il faut souvenir une chose de
l'époque de weimar le gouvernement
allemand même s'il est à l'intérim à
plein pouvoirs exécutifs
la constitution allemande dihk le
gouvernement allemand et il ya toujours
un gouvernement avec le gouvernement
intérim avec moins de pau pour exécutif
c'est le cas par exemple en belgique
un gouvernement technique juste les
affaires quoi exactement le même ce
n'est pas le cas donc est ce qu on
pourrait continuer avons à faire avancer
les choses en europe avec ce
gouvernement maintenant on pourrait
parfaitement
oui mais après la problématique c'est de
faire voter en fait des lois alors que
angela merkel pour le coup chancelière
par intérim n'a pas de majorité philippe
juvin regarder la question précise de la
zone euro à approfondir ou pas qui est
un vrai sujet où nous considérons qu'il
faut approfondir la zone euro qui peut
penser un instant que les allemands sans
gouvernement
enfin dans la situation actuelle je
souhaite qu'ils en aient mais dans la
situation actuelle puisse avoir une
position politique claire franche qu'ils
vont porter non c'était pas possible
malheureusement il ya une certaine
bocage ya certains blocages mais qui
aurait de toute façon été bloquée
certainement par le camp des libéraux
qui était potentiellement en négociation
avec la vidéo c est sous bonne garde
quand même une espèce de glissade vers
le ft autrichien maria reina est ce que
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
l'europe que les libéraux se soient
extraits de même
alors bien sûr les libéraux allemands
sont plutôt eurosceptiques et donc à
voir dans un gouvernement allemand des
libéraux qui ont quand même un jeu
important à l'intérieur de cette
négociation
et bien c'est effectivement aussi risqué
pour l'europe
donc je pense que toute hypothèse
aujourd'hui qui va être prise au niveau
allemand sera bien entendu une hypothèse
qui va venir bousculer des projets des
projets européens bien entendu porté par
emmanuel macron ernest rotation non je
veux souligner c'est tout à fait vrai un
accord entre merkel et le spd et les
verts sur la question de la zone euro
rapprocher les positions allemandes eux
les conditions macro avec les libéraux
il n'y aurait pas eu raison de la zone
euro c'était absolument impossible donc
bon du point de vue de la réforme la
zone euro la non entrée des libéraux
c'est une chance
bon bah écoutez nous suivrons bien
entendu cette actualité en france depuis
quelques semaines je ne vous cache pas
que le grand débat c'est la question de
l'âge du consentement sexuel l'âge du
consentement sexuel est arrivé dans le
débat car une jeune fille de 11 ans dit
avoir été violée et son violeur a été
innocenté devant une course qui pose en
fait la question de l'âge du
consentement sexuel
nicole belloubet était au micro de tam
tran huy il y a quelques jours en écoute
ce que nous savons
c'est que nous voulons encore mieux
protéger les enfants qu'ils ne le sont
aujourd'hui
et pour ce faire nous imaginons que
rendre à un âge limite où la présomption
de consentement sera présumé ne pas
exister est indispensable pour mieux
assurer cette protection
cela étant je suis parfaitement
consciente des enjeux juridiques que
cela suppose et c'est la raison pour
laquelle pour laquelle nous d'en avoir
une réflexion un peu plus abouti avant
d'avancer de manière absolument certaine
sur le seuil 13 ans 14 ans 15 ans il y à
des expériences européennes différentes
et donc nous allons prendre appui sur
ses expériences dialoguer également avec
les parlementaires qui sont impliqués
sur ces questions là pour choisir la
meilleure option possible
alors le consentement sexuel l'âge du
consentement sexuel en angleterre ou en
suisse on considère qu'un acte sexuel
relève automatiquement d'un viol sur une
personne de moins de 16 dans le danemark
c'est 15 en belgique autriche 14 en
espagne etats unis 12 ans est ce que on
peut dire que en dessous de 13 ans comme
potentiellement ce serait le cas en
france on est potentiellement violet
quoi qu'il arrive ou est-ce que ça
paraît quand même encore un peu jeunes
comme seule maria arena qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé que ce qui donne là où
ce qui doit nous guider c'est la
protection des mineurs ce qui est
surtout important c'est de pouvoir
régler la question de la relation d'un
mineur avec un majeur et c'est sur cet
axe là en tout cas qu'en belgique nous
avons travaillé c'est pour la majorité
sexuelle il y a un âge mais dans le
cadre de la question du viol donc et
plus particulièrement de la relation
avec un majeur
et bien il y a là une appréciation à
pouvoir avoir et peut-être un sentiment
d'aggravation quand il s'agit d'une
relation avec un majeur parce qu' il
peut y avoir si il n'y a pas la preuve
du consentement il peut y avoir
manipulation de l'appareil majeur fils
du vent on est presque dans du cas par
cas finalement oui alors c'est que c'est
pas parce qu'un enfant ne se défend pas
qu'il est consentant veut et la
libération en fait ils venaient voir
landais sidération de soumission à une
situation une incapacité à se défendre
et donc
il ya vite évidemment un trou dans la
raquette de la législation française
cette affaire lamentable une petite
fille de 11 ans qui a un rapport sexuel
avec un homme de 28 ans il n'ya pas
violent parce que soi-disant elle était
consentante et folle pour nous voulons
un seuil il faut qu'il ya un seuil
d'automaticité de la définition du viol
12 13 14 15 16 je ne sais pas
probablement plus mais au jeu 15 12 mais
après cet état de sidération et un as
tout aux états unis il n'est pas
forcément aussi liée à l'âge on
discutait en préparant cette émission de
ce qui s'est passé à pampelune un viol
collectif durant les fêtes de pampelune
j'ose imaginer que la victime était
également peut-être en état de
sidération à ce que c'est une question
liée à l'âge selon vous c'est une
question palais à l'âge mais en tout cas
je pense que je rejoins ce que marc et
aimerait rennes à 10 dans le cas des
mineurs le l'intérêt de mineurs doit
prévaloir dans le cas de bien sûr de ce
qui s'est passé à un complot nous on est
bien sûr dans un cadre d'un viol massif
affreux skis mais ce qui m'inquiète de
plus de 2 ce cas là c'est que en ce
moment en espagne on assiste à une
double accusation d'un manque seulement
la victime a été violée mais maintenant
les gens qui l'ont violée sont en train
de démontrer de d'essayer de démontrer
devant le juge que en fait la fille a
refait sa vie qu'elle vit sa vie en
plein normalité et donc qu'elle était
victime n est pas victime elle a pas
vraiment un trop moi je trouve ça
absolument scandaleux parce qu'on a un
problème aussi avec la question de la
violence envers les femmes c'est le rôle
de certains juges qui ne comprennent
absolument rien à ce que c'est la
violence envers les femmes en espagne ça
c'est un vrai vrai problème et ça c'est
une question qui font un certain moment
si on discute barrière est là comment on
fait justement pour répondre à ces
problématiques
quand on a une justice quand on a des
médias potentiellement quand on a une
société civile en fait qui a tendance
aussi à pointer la responsabilité de la
victime
alors c'est tout le travail qui doit
être fait sur un plan d'action contre
les violences faites aux femmes
aujourd'hui un outil qui est un très bel
outil pour travailler sur la violence
faite aux femmes qui s'appelle la
convention d'istanbul qui est une
convention dans lesquelles les pays
qu'ils ratifient cette convention qui
adhère à la convention doivent mettre en
place un plan systématique de lutte
contre la violence faite aux femmes qui
va de la prévention de la formation des
jeux
des filières d'informations entre la
police les juges le dépôt de plainte
les médecins qui doivent faire des
certificats et donc c'est vraiment un
plan d'action concret qui permet de
venir attaquer les différents phénomènes
de violence à l'égard des femmes est
aussi de modifier les stéréotypes
structurels comme on a aujourd'hui dans
nos sociétés parce que s'il y a des
violences faites aux femmes
c'est qu'il y à des stéréotypes
machistes qui prévalent dans nos
sociétés aujourd'hui un sondage a été
mené par amnesty international qui
indiquent un quart des femmes dans les
pays sondés en europe ont été victimes
de cyber harcèlement et ça pour le coup
il n'y a rien de prévu en termes
législatifs nous on l'a vu en france il
y a quelques semaines suite justement à
toute cette affaire ou einstein balances
ton port etc
des jeunes gens sur un forum qui
s'appelle jeuxvideo.com ont attaqué des
des activistes ont attaqué des
journalistes philippe juvin mais cela
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un flou juridique
là-dessus qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut là aussi taper sur les gaffes à
écouter d'abord je pense que les gaffes
à google facebook et trucs et bidules
ont une responsabilité puisque
aujourd'hui ils ne sont responsables de
rien quand il publie un contenu moi je
pense qu'il doit avoir un certain niveau
de responsabilité et j'y travaille
actuellement parlement mais ça va bien
au delà
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui si vous tapez
sur google le mot clé du nom du journal
je ne donne pas de dh
vous avez en première page de google le
journal de neige qui vous explique
comment tu quelqu'un comment on pose une
bombe et le mans n'ont pas eu quelqu'un
donc et tout ça google vous ne vous
répond même pas quand vous leur écrivait
ils vous disent amène en liberté donc je
pense qu'il ya un vrai sujet sur la
responsabilité des plateformes
maintenant sur les questions de
harcèlement il ya un arsenal législatif
sur le harcèlement
vous n'avez pas le droit de harceler que
ce soit par téléphone mais si elle s'est
comportée comme des forums où les gens
sont tannés parce que y'a l'anonymat
donc évidemment la même règle doit
s'appliquer dans les messages anonymes
publiée sur le net que dans le monde
physique parce qu'en fait d'une certaine
manière
internet c'est le retour de la
légitimation du courrier anonyme oui
vous allez d'accord à ce sujet m marina
est ce qu'il faut lever cette
anonymisation du web
moi ça m'inquiète ça m'inquiète
particulièrement vis-à-vis des d'aider
des jeunes
moi moi j'ai une soeur bègue qui est
dense et à 15 ans et moi quand je vois
le niveau de violence en verve à ce
moment vers elle mais ont baissé que de
certains copains dont il ya un véritable
harcèlement
il ya un vrai un véritable harcèlement
dans le cadre des jeunes qui reproduit
un mépris envers les femmes et ses
droits et ça m'inquiète parce que c'est
ça arrive dans les jeunes alors là faut
absolument agir et bien sûr la question
de la limite est quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut voir comment on corrige
maria rennaise que le parlement et la
commission femmes dont vous faites
partie avec un instauration de cci de
ces questions alors on a eu un rapport
sur le cas du harcèlement sur les
réseaux sociaux donc tout ce qui est la
digitalisation de notre économie et ce
qui passe par ces digitalisation alors
il ya bien entendu beaucoup de choses
positives mais il faut aussi attaquer
les choses négatives qui peuvent se voir
sur sur la toile et donc il ya eu un
rapport qui a été réalisé alors c'est
tout l'équilibré qu'on doit trouver
entre la liberté d'expression et la
limite de cette liberté d'expression et
je suis assez contente de voir qu'on a
un partenaire du parti populaire
européen qui dit qu'il faut réguler cela
qu'il faut des règles par rapport à ces
grandes entreprises
on a parlé des règles par rapport à
l'heure où dre américain mona
problématique de la ligue 1 oui gestion
puisque la question c'est elles sont
sous droit américain mais elles agissent
économiquement culturellement sur le
territoire européen et donc il faut
pouvoir avoir les outils sur le
territoire européen pour pouvoir leur
imposer un certain nombre de règles
on parle ici de la question de la
liberté d'expression et de leurs
responsabilités par rapport à cela on
peut aussi parler de la fiscalité de ces
entreprises et la manière dont ridel
m'envahit leur fils réalité en europe et
donc on doit développer des outils qui
viennent faire en sorte que ces
entreprises qui agissent économiquement
et culturellement sur notre territoire
répond d'un certain nombre de critères
à écouter nous suivrons ce dossier quoi
qu'il en soit depuis quelques semaines
là
france bruisse de nouvelles polémiques
et cela a été lancé par la secrétaire
d'état mme marlène schiappa secrétaire
d'état aux droits des femmes qui a
annoncé que la pma la procréation
médicalement assistée serait ouverte à
toutes les femmes en france en 2018
promesses de campagne d'emmanuel macron
rapidement donc les clés polémique
reprennent envahissent les journaux les
plateaux de télévision nous avons voulu
savoir comment cela se passait au
portugal portugal dernier pays d'europe
à l'avoir mis en oeuvre sous un
gouvernement donc d' alliance de la
gauche
c'est un reportage de cécile 6o qui a
suivi marcia qui essaye d'avoir un bébé
toute seule
reportage tenir une petite main c'est le
rêve de marcia mais pour cette jeune
portugaise avoir un enfant de manière
classique est impossible elle est
homosexuel et célibataire alors à 34 ans
elle a décidé de faire un bébé toute
seule
bonjour bonjour quelle est la date de
vos dernières règles
c'était le 21 octobre dans cette
clinique de lisbonne elle suit un
processus de paix m à une procréation
médicalement assistée dans deux mois si
tout va bien un de ses ovules sera
féconder avec le sperme d'un inconnu
non non ce n'est pas une chose
douloureuse ni impossible à faire mais
c'est fatigant martienne on est pas à sa
première tentative en 2014 elle a déjà
fait deux ans amy nation artificielle
son succès ce n'était pas au portugal
car interdit à ce moment là mais en
espagne
voilà ce qu'il me reste des documents et
papiers de mes premières tentatives
espagne vicente besoin ce sont des
analyses et examens médicaux que j'ai
joint à mon dossier ici au portugal
depuis une loi a été votée dans son pays
en 2016 elle ouvre la pma aux couples
lesbiens et aux femmes seules
désormais les portugaises comme marcia
non plus à payer les allers retours à
l'étranger elles ont le choix de
gratuité en hôpital public et d'autres
avantages au portugal elles ont la
famille et les proches c'est beaucoup
plus facile même en question de travail
le support social et émotionnel la
famille des amis très très très
important dans ces situations si les
démarches sont plus simples elles ne
sont pas plus rapide pour autant marcia
elle ne pouvait plus attendre
elle a préféré payer une clinique privée
même si l'aventuré espagnole lui a déjà
coûté 12 mille euros l'entertainment à
faisait repas travail hp tâche pour
essayer de le faire dans le public à
l'hôpital où c'est moins lourd
financièrement mais il ya une longue
liste d'attentes et oui c'est un gros
effort financier car une fiv
c'est dans les 5000 euros
un coup de sang ce brutal
comment est-ce que vous traduire y est
cela en portugais dans sa vie
quotidienne
marcia assume son choix bonjour au
collège où elle enseigne sa démarche est
plutôt bien vu
chacun a le droit de faire ce qu'il veut
pour son projet de vie je suis maman et
je comprends très bien le désir de
marcia je la soutiens à 100%
voilà je crois vraiment que c'est une
question cette question du pourquoi elle
veut être maire c'est tout
être mère à tout prix pour ce professeur
de bioéthique en ouvrant la pma tout au
portugal on a fait passer le droit
d'avoir des enfants avant celui des
enfants eux mêmes
en d'autres termes on a oublié la
question de la filiation
écoutez vous voulez avoir le droit pas
le droit de pouvoir savoir votre
histoire tout le monde dit oui je veux
avoir le droit si je veux écrire c'est
le droit ça j'ai pas très près mais je
veux savoir qu'ils font mais demi-frère
qui sont mes demi soeur qui a été le
mieux ou la femme qui m'a donné ce
l'espère vont eux aussi avoir le droit
si on ne donne pas le droit aux enfants
adolescents ou jeunes adultes
c'est énorme c'est la détresse se tut
tut finalisé au portugal le don de
sperme est anonyme et une mère
célibataire peut aussi recevoir
l'ovocyte d'une autre femme
c'est cette cuisine du matériel
génétique qui au moment de la discussion
de la loi a fait le plus débat
étonnant dans un des pays les plus
catholiques en europe où les questions
de la famille les questions morales sont
finalement passés au second plan
pour ce député du bloc de gauche qui a
porté la loi
ici c'est une tradition on fait passer
les libertés individuelles avant le
reste c'est juste ça c'est une décision
personnelle pour ces femmes et l'état
n'a pas à interdire des décisions
personnelles qui n'ont aucun impact
négatif sur la société
l'idée c'est juste de permettre à ces
personnes de réaliser leur rêve qu'elles
soient les plus heureuse possible
réaliser son rêve s'offrir un enfant
dans son propre pays
le portugal a ouvert les vannes outre la
pma l'adoption et la gpa dans certains
cas ont aussi été autorisés au pays du
fado
on voit cela comme une avancée et on a
du mal à imaginer ce qui en france fait
débat et qui oblige ces femmes à
traverser les frontières
philippe suivant est ce que ça vous
choque cette réalité non non moi je ne
suis choqué par rien en l'occurrence ma
crainte c'est qu'en france comme nous
sommes les spécialistes des débats à peu
que nous allons devoir rendre abstrait
ouais
ma crainte c'est qu'il y ait deux camps
qui s'affrontent qui chacun est persuadé
d'avoir la vérité et qui considère
l'autre comme un scélérat moi je veux
dire je comprends les gens qui imaginent
que la pma puisse être ouvert pour tous
je ne suis pas loin d'être dans ce camp
là mais je comprends aussi ceux qui se
préoccupent de l'institutionnalisation
d'un monde sans père pour le faire
rapidement
donc le pire qui pourrait nous arriver
dans cette affaire c'est le débat avec
anne athènes et il ya une chose que je
refuse de poser c'est de poser un débat
ce au titre de la lutte contre la
discrimination la question ne doit pas
être là la question elle est sur le
libre choix et sur le devenir de
l'enfant et sur l'idée qu'on se fait de
la filiation
ernesto station de maria reina vous vous
êtes tous les deux parties de payer
assez libre sur ces questions ça fait
bien longtemps que la belgique et
l'espagne en fait permettre cela comment
est ce que vous regardez ces débats
français - non nous avions un cadre
avant qu'ils étaient insérés semblable à
celui qui était qui j'ai eu si j'ai bien
compris en france et que seulement
seulement permis dans le cas d'un couple
stable
maintenant nous avons élargi a bien sûr
à des mères qui sont seules à des
couples de femmes lesbiennes etc
ces thèmes une expérience positif je
pense que ce n'est c'est faux de dire
qu'un enfant va être plus heureux dans
le cadre d'un couple stable que avec une
mère tout seul ça c'est quelque chose de
faux moi je pense que le libre choix
d'après valoir la seule chose c'est bien
sûr le modèle espagnol a aussi des
enjeux qui doivent êtres qui doivent
être débattues nous avons tout d'abord
un business privé très grand qui
s'élargit irait tourisme processus est
un enjeu nous nous en tant que vers nous
défendons bien sûr que ça doit être le
cas la santé publique doit être le
centre de cette activité bien sûr pas
que ça devienne un bon business public
et ça c'est ça c'est vraiment un enjeu
qui fait qu'il faut qu'il faut voir
comment réseau mais en tout cas moi je
pense que si la france avance vers un
élargissement de
de ce droit moi je pense que ce sera
positif a dans d'autres pays ceci a eu
un impact positif dans la société marié
arena ce tourisme procréatif vous le
connaissez aussi en belgique
sk pas effectivement là pour le coup
business des enfants alors ils ont
accepté qu on est en belgique dans une
situation où ce sont des hôpitaux
publics qui sont les hôpitaux de la
fertilité qui réalise effectivement la
question de la pma oui clairement
19 quand même nom excepté que vous êtes
vraiment dans le champ public l'objectif
n'est pas de faire de l'argent mais de
répondre à un besoin qui a été exprimé
par une personne donc l'objectif n'est
pour elle termine à lille et électeurs
c'est les cliniques heavy qu'on voit
dans ce reportage et qui sont pour
beaucoup aussi en espagne ce sont les
cliniques privées où effectivement la
pma coûte 8010 1012 minéraux l'objectif
n'est pas de faire de l'argent et donc
c'est de répondre c'est d'offrir un
service public à une personne qui en
expriment le besoin et donc on est
vraiment dans ce cadre là qu est un
cadre extrêmement je dirais accompagner
et donc avec un vrai travail de la
personne qui est en demande et du suivi
de cette personne qui est un vrai
service public à la personne donc je
rejoins aussi à l'aise ernest
importations pour dire il faut qu'on le
retire d'un champ privé l'objectif n'est
pas d'en faire du business et pas d'en
faire de l'argent n'est pas de dire un
enfant coûte au temps où un enfant voilà
autant en attendant syndicats mais alors
le problème c'est que quand vous avez
des législations aussi différente entre
les différents états membres
et vous avez effectivement la mobilité
des uns et des autres qui peuvent aller
à l'intérieur de l'europe mais ils
peuvent aussi aller à l'extérieur de
l'europe et donc je pense qu'il est
intéressant qu'on puisse se poser la
question ici au niveau européen de ce
que ça a comme enjeu d'avoir des pays
des pays avec des législations
différentes sur la question werner
question on voit que c'est aussi une
question sociale à l'âge fin à leur
pardon ou l'âge d'entrer sur le marché
du travail est de plus en plus tardif
pour les femmes
je pense notamment aux italiennes dont
le premier cdi est en moyenne à 36 ans
alors qu'on parlait de précarité tout à
l'heure est ce que ces questions en fait
de pme ou de vitrification des ovocytes
ne doit pas aussi être posée
d'un point de vue social maria reina
airness orthez oui bien sûr je pense
qu'aujourd'hui si on est si on n'est pas
stable économiquement parlant c'est très
difficile d'envisager à 30 ans d'avoir
un enfant et donc on retarde la
maternité malheureusement la biologie
fait que bon on peut pas la retarder
jusqu'au moment où on veut entendre à la
main économique et donc c'est aussi une
question économique de pouvoir planifier
correctement le moment où on veut avoir
un enfant et où on est capable d'avoir
cet enfant biologiquement et donc
effectivement c'est important et à
l'instauration des gaffes à je me
souviens de google à une époque qui
proposait de payer la vitrification des
ovocytes de ses employés est ce qu'il
faut qu'on en arrive là c'est à ce
moment moi moi je pense que franchement
ça doit être un choix personnel
il faut respecter ce choix l'état doit
protéger ce choix et c'est là moi je
pense que c'est la santé publique qui
doit qui doit être en mesure de répondre
à cette volonté des femmes que librement
décide d'avoir un enfeu le reste
franchement et particulièrement de
convertir sa dans un grand business de
demander aux femmes de payer 14 mille
euros pour avoir un enfant vous disais
tout à l'heure le presque c'est le prix
d'un enfant 14000 euros
je pense que là on est absolument dans
un 4e chrono mais le rejeter
on aurait plutôt intérêt à offrir plus
de stabilité aux femmes le plus tôt
possible
plutôt qu'à de retarder leur stabilité
et leur imposer finalement quelque chose
qu'elle qu'elle préférait faire avant je
trouve qu avoir annoncé avoir un enfant
à 30 ans et en ayant la possibilité
d'avoir une carrière professionnelle
c'est beaucoup plus épanouissant et donc
je pense qu'on a plutôt travaillé sur
cet équilibre vie privée vie
professionnelle et de garantir à ces
femmes de pouvoir assumer
c'est de ces deux rôles plutôt que
d'avoir à en passer par justement c'est
après en europe il ya je crois que ça en
europe 1,4 million d'enfants qui sont
nés par procréation médicalement
assistée donc c'est pas un nouveau sujet
c'est un vieux sujet mais on voit bien
avec tous les exemples qui sont données
combien ce sujet qui était bien
identifiés devient un peu fou la
vitrification proposées par votre
employeur
à thé de deux primes de charles trenet
mais valérie va t-on au regard des
volumes questions économiques à partir
du moment où la précarisation du marché
du travail où les femmes entre plus
tardivement sur le marché du travail
ensuite avoué ou arrêtez-vous la
lactation une dérive de l'égalité totale
vous voyez ce qu'on peut imaginer même
dans ce cas là qu'on puisse vous vendre
un enfant mais évidemment je sais que ce
n'est pas ça mais ça dérive on peut
inventer des mots des bons de fou donc
il faut garder la tête froide en est pas
vouloir régler toutes les questions que
malheureusement le la nature non mais la
contraction économique devra de toute
façon été réglé sinon effectivement ce
sont des questions notamment la pma pour
toutes qu'on risque de se poser encore
longtemps nous avons le débat sur la
directive sur le congé de maternité et
paternité qui est absolument on n'a pas
été en mesure encore de la flotte d'en
faire une réalité c'est beaucoup plus
important de se faire des efforts sur ce
lac d'orta imaginer que la
multinationale va payer non franchement
c'est bon mais écoutez au moins vous
êtes d'accord
merci en tout cas de nous avoir éclairé
c'est sur ces questions c'est la fin de
l'émission
mais pas de panique vous nous retrouver
la semaine prochaine ici à bruxelles
c'est bruxelles la semaine prochaine
avec ahmed tazir très belle semaine à
tous ciao
[Musique]